mobilisation record en France contre la
réforme des retraites sur le vieux port
de Marseille dans les outre-mer et aussi
au cœur de Paris
un million 280 mille personnes selon la
police 3 millions 500000 selon les
syndicats avec humour la CGT a sorti les
déambulateurs devant la centrale
nucléaire de saint-alban-saint-maurice
merci au cas où si la réforme passe et
que l'âge de départ à la retraite est
repoussée cette symbolique s'est adapté
nos outils de travail demain pour
pouvoir aller jusqu'à 64 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de notre pays la plus forte journée de
mobilisation depuis le début janvier un
temps fort un temps massif on est
vraiment aujourd'hui dans un enjeu de
continuer et de continuer en montant
d'un crâne
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron a réussi la convergence
d'élite car les Gaulois réfractaires
disent d'abord non au prince ce
président qui parle trop bien l'anglais
de Harvard et si mal le français de
Vierzon Emmanuel Macron est un paradoxe
c'est lui à 39 ans réélu à 44 ans sa
personnalité son parcours son attitude
cristallise les rancoeurs les Français
d'en bas n'aiment pas ce héros de Paris
Match qui traverse la vie sans blessure
Emmanuel Macron premier il y a le roi sa
cour qui applique les décisions et les
interdictions et tout ça bien bien bien
doigt sur la couture du pantalon comme
ça et puis il y a il y a tous les autres
à la plèbe là comme il a dit lui-même et
ça lui a échappé qui ne sont rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a l'impression que tout le monde
déteste ce pays toute façon Sarkozy on
le détestait Hollande on l'a détesté ma
cron on le déteste et de toute façon le
suivant le détestera et quoi qu'il
arrive c'est une culture j'ai reçu une
culture
d'argent tu l'as mis tout au fond tout
au fond de tes chiottes la présidente
selfie d'Emmanuel Macron pardon je pense
que les Français ils ont un peu marre
mais oui
moi qui suis un peu expert en boîte de
nuit tout je trouve que les yeux un
petit peu vite j'ai une carrière avant
ça veut dire quoi ah bah moi partir de
14-15 ans je suis beaucoup sorti
de la cellule des macronisation de la
réforme des retraites alors comment on
fait
c'est quoi il y en a partout
et alors 24 heures vous êtes à l'abri
d'ici 2033 40% des corvées ménagères
seront exécutés par des robots et c'est
déjà au fait en partie le cas
aujourd'hui puisqu'on peut utiliser des
robots pour de nombreux stages du
quotidien comme passer l'aspirateur
cuisiner ou réformer les retraites
franchement c'est très fort mais ne
passe par-dessus la tête mais pour moi
tous ceux qui ont moins de 52 ans à
l'heure actuelle il devrait même pas
sentir concerné puis dans les 10 ans qui
viennent il va encore en avoir une
nouvelle et je pense que si le seul
problème qu'on a en France c'est de
savoir s'il faut bosser deux ans de plus
bassete que tout va bien elle est bien
la réforme
pourquoi vous manifestez alors parce que
je manifeste je manifeste contre la
réforme en fait d'accord des routes
saturées des poids lourds au ralenti et
des barrages pour empêcher bus et camion
poubelle de sortir par tout le même
on bloque le pays au moment ben ça
bloque on attend ah bah oui je comprends
j'ai 25 ans j'ai mes parents ils
approchent de la retraite au fur et à
mesure au plus approches au plus on a
sans qu'elle s'éloigne
des
compréhensifs on voulait voir comment ça
se passe sur le périph et ça roule
plutôt bien il y a une circulation
normale c'est-à-dire que oui il y a eu
un appel au télétravail c'est vrai mais
les gens sont quand même un petit peu au
boulot il y a très peu de bouchons et
les automobilistes qu'on croise bah
écoutez sont plutôt sont plutôt
optimistes quant à la journée
d'aujourd'hui voilà on se fait klaxonner
avec des grands signes comme ça donc
c'est plutôt sympa c'est avec un peu
d'organisation vous voyez ça se passe
pas trop mal et Anne va partir attention
voilà ça va voilà
voilà ce qui peut se passer quand
justement on court on essaie d'attraper
le seul train qui part voilà ça c'est en
revanche le type de difficulté qui peut
qui peut survenir aujourd'hui il y a
école aujourd'hui c'est dommage non au
contraire c'est très très bien qui est
école hein
la grève tu t'en fous non moi j'aime pas
la grève j'adore l'école ce matin gare
de Lyon pneu allumé avec la délicatesse
de Babette tordant un point cuisson
résultat embrouille entre grévistes
pour pour faire le feu là vous voulez
devenir désolé c'est ça désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore
[Musique]
on va ranger la prochaine fois tu mets
moins de bonheur oh [__] engueuler je
me fais engueuler de sa faute
c'est magique c'est magique sérieux
c'est magique le vrai problème c'est pas
la retraite le vrai problème c'est pas
le pouvoir d'achat le vrai poème c'est
pas l'inflation des trucs comme ça ça ce
sont des prétextes dont on se sert bien
évidemment il y a un changement de fond
qui est en jeu actuellement la langue
durée des histoires du Maine disait
brodel et bien c'est le fait qu'on est
en train de passer d'une société à une
autre chaque trois siècles cela se passe
c'est ainsi on va y retrouver l'une des
reporters de BFM TV sur place de ce côté
de de la place d'Italie pour pouvoir ces
tensions toujours en cours ou pas
c'est en train de partir en couille je
crois qu'on peut le dire donc si vous
voulez un live ce serait bien de pas
trop traîner je pense
non mais en fait non pardon c'était le
Off c'était avant qu'elle soit en direct
voilà alors en même temps c'est une
expression assez parlante mais quelle
société vous me fait peur il faut avoir
peur il faut avoir peur c'est
laquelle celle qui arrive rassurez-moi
non mais c'est laquelle c'est laquelle
c'est laquelle celle qui arrive bien
certain l'appellent la pause modernité
je suis de ceux-là c'est-à-dire où les
grandes valeurs la valeur travail ne
sera plus à l'ordre du jour ou à bien
des égards le rationalisme ne sera plus
à l'ordre du jour où le progressisme ne
sera plus à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas plus d'informations
pour le moment pour les collèges et pour
les lycées même si on sait des blocages
pour addict sont attendus dans les
lycées et dans les facultés et puis dans
les non c'était tout voilà je crois que
c'est déjà pas mal